friend of mine sent me this article
earlier it's very interesting lawsuits
filed against insurers in recent years
for their practices around Universal
Life Insurance highlight the risks that
these products can pose to unwary
financial advisors and their clients
Transamerica a AXA lincoln national or
examples of firms and the cross fire of
litigation raising the cost of insurance
in a certain universal for raising the
cost of insurance and certain universal
policies nationwide life insurance
company also privately settled a lawsuit
with two individuals in may relative to
variable universal life insurance cost
john hancock said a lawsuit related to
universal life insurance costs 491
million unlike other products like term
and whole life universal life which is
permanent cash value life insurance
allows buyers to make flexible premium
payments that flexibility allows buyers
to fund policies with a relatively low
amount of premiums to keep the insurance
going however a cost increase could
leave these clients with an unattractive
choice pay a much higher annual bill to
keep the contract to float or lapse the
policy altogether they don't know what
they can do says James Hunt a consumer
federation of America's life insurance
actuary they paid a premium and they
thought they paid for life and now
they're facing extremely high premiums
to keep them going the recent wave of
lawsuits which began cropping up around
2015 of targeted universal life policies
sold in the 80s and 90s insurers offered
an attractive guaranteed minimum
interest rate to policyholders of about
four to five percent supported by higher
interest rates set by the federal
government during this time but a decade
of rock-bottom interest rates in the
wake of their financial crisis hurt
insurers profitability reducing the
return on the bonds and underpinning
their products and so they jacked the
rates so here's what happens with the
universal life policy why these things
are happening why people are pissed off
about it
so you're told that if you pay a premium
you'll have the policy your whole life a
portion of the premium goes to pay for
the insurance and a portion goes into
your investment called a cash value the
problem is these things are based on the
insurance inside of them is based on an
AR T which is an annual renewable term
if you think about it every year you
live you're more likely to die
statistically a forty six year olds more
likely to live to die statistically than
a 45 year old on average a 76 year old
is more likely to die than a 56 year old
on average statistically speaking so
they charge more it costs more because
of the probability of death to ensure
someone who's older everybody get that
and so if the let's say you had $100 a
month with $200 a month premium okay and
if it started out at age 35 and the cost
to cover you at age 35 was $50 a month
of the 200 then you'd have 150 going the
investment that should be just fine
right but then what happens is over time
the cost to cover you let's say let's
get you up to age 60 might be two
hundred and fifty dollars but you're
only paying two hundred where's the
other $50 come from it's eating your
savings up that you put in and so your
insurance cost goes up every year to the
point that it passes the premium and
eats up the savings when the savings is
gone the insurance company comes to you
knocking on your door and says now it
costs $300 a month for you to just have
insurance no savings because not only
have as the increasing premium eaten up
what you were paying or the increasing
cost of insurance eating up your premium
but it's also going over that eating up
your savings now there's nothing left
and we're not gonna cover you anymore
unless you pay this new higher premium
for insurance only you just got screwed
by behind a bad badly designed horrible
financial product
and so when all these guys are if you
don't understand index Universal yeah
the flexible premium yes I do understand
it and I've seen this happen I've met
with these people and they're 65 years
old and their insurance that they paid
into for 40 years has completely self
destructed and now they're standing
there with nothing and they paid huge
premiums if they have paid one twentieth
as much they'd had term insurance over
all that same twenty year period of time
and they could have invested and then
nobody's going to tinker with their
investments and steal their investments
to pay insurance premiums to some dadgum
insurance company if it if you're if
your insurance product has if you have a
life insurance policy that has a savings
component to it it's building up cash
value you're getting screwed the worst
of the worst are these things actually
the worst of the worst of the
old-fashion whole life policies these
things are right behind them but at
least the whole whole life policies
they're bad as they are they're
absolutely horrendous
it's the payday lender the middle-class
but at least they don't self-destruct
and leave you standing there with none
of your money these things you can
affect flexible premium universal life
policy each you alive and then people
are so pissed off they sue and that's
what's happening 91 million dollars one
of those companies paid whoa baby
I bet that wasn't fun well he was a good
idea drop that crap and get you some
term insurance go to Xandar insurance
calm
[Music]